[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show there has been
a mass stabbing in canada
the latest is that one suspect has been
found dead and one is still on the run
and 10 people are believed dead in the
stabbings this is
um
a stabbing that took place in an
indigenous community indigenous
community
and in a nearby town in saskatchewan
and police are charging both suspects
with murder
and other counts and this is in canada
one of the biggest manhunts and
deadliest mass killings in the history
of the country the men are also
suspected of injuring 19 people in
addition to the 10 that died one of the
suspects the 31 year old was found dead
outside of a house being examined on the
james smith cree nation with visible
injuries that did not appear
self-inflicted so they don't yet know
that
believed stabber
might have been killed
might have taken his own life but
doesn't appear that way as of right now
the brother who is 30 years old remains
the focus of a search as of this moment
police say it's possible he's injured
but they didn't confirm whether they
believe
that the 31 year old ended up dead at
the hands of the 30 year old it's all
crazy
their people are being advised to
consider them armed and dangerous and of
course this is being used pat by the
pro-gun right to say we told you
we told you that the stabbings can be
just as dangerous as the shootings and
of course when you look at the fact that
this was a series of knife attacks in
multiple locations over a period of time
no one could look at this and say if
they had ar-15s and did this number of
of shootings
uh
fewer people would have died it would
have been much more but they don't care
pat they don't care right this is an
outlier case and so that's exactly why
we're hearing about it yeah and
typically when you have a stabbing and
someone is trying to
kill or attack the most amount of people
possible maybe they can get away with
being successful with a few people but
10 is
not something that most can accomplish
that's partly why this took place in
multiple locations and thoroughly why
there was a manhunt still going on 13
crime scenes is what people have to
understand so of course this is
horrifying and knives can be deadly but
it took 13 crime scenes to do this
amount of damage
imagine 13 ar-15 mass shootings in a day
yeah especially when people will point
out well this is probably an area that
doesn't have a lot of police it'll take
the sheriff's deputy a long time to get
over to the location wherever the crime
went down well you can also point out
then that's part of the reason why it
would be dangerous for the attackers to
have guns with them because then they
would have been able to kill a lot more
people correct time because it's not
very heavily policed and uh yeah very
tragic story the motive is still unclear
at this point and you know as we learn
more about that there may be another
political angle to that too that we can
talk about it's not clear if they were
just trying to attack as many people as
possible some allege that this may have
been drug related some of the targets
were known by the suspects whereas
others were not known by the suspects so
it doesn't seem like it was completely
random but that would be another angle
to this too as well like if they were
trying to um you know get the attention
of the media if they were trying to make
a point but at this clear at this point
it's just we don't know the motive yet
nope we don't and we know that it's
horrible we know that it's tragic we
know that political uh forces in the
united states are trying to use this to
their advantage and
you know
we we've reported on mass stabbings
before and many of them are one crime
scene or two
and in most of them nobody dies that's
the reality of the ones we've reported
on that make headlines this is different
and the fact that there was a mass
stabbing in 13 crime scenes in canada
doesn't really say anything about what
american gun policy should be
right well it's just like when there's
one specific
gun safety measure that wouldn't stop
any specific mass shooting right likes
to say okay well then there's no point
of having any gun regulations it's all
just moot uh there's we should just do
away with it all you're going to be able
to find these outlier incidences where
there's like one case where whatever law
you come up with isn't going to save
people in that particular case it
doesn't mean that you shouldn't have an
all-of-the-above
sort of approach when dealing with these
issues just because it's not going to
solve every issue of course of course
we'll continue to follow i am curious if
motive is determined then there is an
active manhunt right now
maybe by tomorrow we will have more
information a judge in the united states
has dismissed a man's lawsuit against
the band nirvana over the band's 1991
album cover which showed him naked as a
baby now i don't know how many people
are familiar with this album cover but
it is quite well known there is an album
cover for the nirvana album never mind
in which there is a dollar bill on a
sort of fish hook
in the water and then a naked baby the
naked baby is 31 year old spencer eldon
and spencer eldon now argues that his
photograph on the cover
is child sex abuse the judge said
you left it too late to claim that you
were actually exploited by this
his legal avenues are now all but
exhausted he can't refile the case but
he can appeal this decision and his
legal team says that he will
and um
he argues
he was a baby he couldn't have consented
there's no way he could have consented
and so he wants hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in damages now one of
the defendants is the photographer of
the picture kirk weddle
um and former nirvana members dave grohl
uh and others and courtney love as well
the widow of the late singer kurt cobain
all are defendants
he says he's mr eldon says he's within
his rights to complain because it
continues to cause him distress and lost
earnings
and the lawsuit was dismissed and then
refiled
and at this point the los angeles judge
ruled you're beyond the 10-year statute
of limitations it took place more than
10 years ago so you were beyond the
statute of limitations
the defense argued that elden enjoyed
being the nirvana baby and even
reenacted the photograph later in life
and um indicated that the parents were
paid for the photo it was 200 but they
were paid
and that at that point based on his age
the parents are consenting for the child
and that that's it so kind of a
complicated case emotionally the
legality of it does seem kind of cut and
dry pat
right yeah i don't think eldon has much
of a case here and you gotta wonder does
he genuinely feel like he was hurt by
having this album photo out there or is
he just trying to make a quick buck
because
you know you can't tell for sure what's
going on there but i do get the sense
that he came up with this case as a way
to get himself some money
and it's probably not the best idea to
have naked babies on album art like
maybe we should just put a stop to that
going forward yeah but this is a very
iconic image i'm sure most in the
audience have seen even if you're not a
nirvana fan um and there's definitely
some like benefit to that some some
clout to that that eldon has like he can
sort of use it as a claim to fame it's
one of those things that are unique
about him that he can talk about at
parties and that sort of thing right so
like i i we can't entirely understand
his motive we don't know if he's
actually been hurt by this he says lost
earnings i'd like to well i'm interested
in that because i could imagine a couple
different things one argument would be
when he applies for a job and people
google him they find a picture of him
naked as a baby on the cover of a
nirvana album and then the employer is
like
i don't know this is weird let's hire
somebody else right like what that would
be one argument another argument would
be
the emotional damage prevents him from
working right like that's a totally
different explanation i don't know what
explanation he gives for the lot lost
earnings
yeah i suppose i mean having naked
pictures of you on the internet could
potentially hurt your employment chances
but you you don't typically associate
that with babies no like naked babies
okay you're not going to have your
employment chances hurt most of us would
think that anyway
like if someone was applying to work at
our company for example if this was um
elden trying to get a job david pakman
show maybe i wouldn't care about this
yeah yes you would dismiss this right
you'd be like oh that's interesting
facts about you but it wouldn't help or
hurt his chances total non-factor yeah
absolutely uh okay so we'll see
there's one more appeal left let us know
if you think
uh does elden have a case you know let
us know your thoughts and then we'll
we'll go from there
ron desantis has done a voter front a
voter fraud hunt he is hunting for voter
fraud and it seems to have backfired
election officials across florida
reports axios are poking holes in the
desantis administration's claims that
they're to blame after 20 people were
arrested for voting illegally
supervisors of elections in a number of
florida counties
say it is the state's responsibility to
tell local offices about people who are
ineligible to vote because of felony
convictions a pete antonacci who
desantis appointed as head of elections
investigations
contradicted the governor's claims by
saying to local election officials and a
supervisor local officials in a letter
that they were not at fault in allowing
the felons to vote in 2020 so that this
is so important because
desantis has been making the claim
all of these people
voted despite having convictions which
should prevent them from voting and so
we've got to figure out what the hell
these counties were doing and then it
turns out it's actually the
responsibility of the state
which desantis runs to communicate that
status to the local election supervisors
meaning it's nobody's fault but
desantis's own administration that this
happened yeah he should have some egg on
his face over this although his
supporters aren't going to care they'll
watch the initial press conference where
he makes this big announcement about how
he's going after people who committed
voter fraud and these are felons by the
way people who are convicted of sex
crimes or murder charges that sort of
thing and so it's okay to lock them up
and throw away the key again for this
voter fraud charge uh it's it's what
desantis does though like he tries to
find a culture war issue he's done with
so many of these other issues and he
tries to have something tangible
associated with it being you know
executive order a law that he signs or
in this case just this announcement that
he's going to target these people yep um
and
it depends on what day of the week it is
like sometimes he'll go after
uh voter fraud sometimes he'll go after
police and talk about how he wants to
fund the police when others want to
defund the police he'll do the future
the teacher stuff the teacher stuff yeah
and so this day of the week it was time
to talk about voter fraud and he thought
that he had this big own even though
it's hard to often find people who
actually
committed voter fraud and you know the
prosecutions of such crime are few and
far between because very few people do
it he thought he had this rock solid
case of people he could go after with
this and it's backfiring on him i like
to see it now understandably
some of the people who voted and were
subsequently arrested for voting
said they thought they were allowed to
vote and i get why okay
in 2018 we covered this at the time
florida voters approved a ballot measure
to give voting rights back to people
with prior felony convictions but
it had an exception for those convicted
of murder and felony sex offense now
that's an important exception i'm not
denying the importance of that but that
exception did not make the biggest news
the ballot measure did
and so i understand
some
people
thinking oh i'm okay to vote now even
though they weren't like that doesn't
that doesn't mean it's okay or whatever
but then some of the folks were there
you know their houses were raided there
was one guy pulled out of bed in his
underwear for the arrest for voting
illegally and it's it's all pretty wild
yeah like the appropriate response to
someone voting who was ineligible would
be that they should show up and they
give their name to the poll worker and
it turns out okay actually you can't
vote yes the vote gets tossed or you
know if they vote by mail or something
it gets discounted it shouldn't be going
after them in such a way
and you know it should be incumbent on
the election officials to know who's
eligible and who's not especially when
you have some sort of confusion over
that and uh you know it's interesting
that they even had those carve outs to
begin with i take it it was just a way
to make it more likely to pass
so you say okay well we're going to
re-enfranchise people but it's going to
exclude people who did the worst
criminal offenses in my mind if you
served your time
and your you know you've rehabilitated
yourself you should be able to have
those rights restored but the laws on
the books are that those people are not
able to vote those people have to be
informed that they still can't
especially when there's a time of
confusion a recent bill passed like that
a referendum um and so if the state's
not going to do that that's that's more
incumbent on the state than the people i
think i completely agree and we'll see
how these cases are all now adjudicated
but something about it just kind of
stinks uh hey real quick where are you
on this dark brandon stuff pat like i i
still am not totally sure whether it
started as kind of a joke and has become
real or if it's still a joke or whatnot
i'm sort of using it satirically and
seriously in that
biden has been doing better than ever in
the last three months i'm genuinely
happy with a lot of the things he's
doing i'm genuinely happy with the
attitude he's taking towards republicans
as i pointed out on the podcast today
but i still think dark brandon is
probably satire but it kind of became
real in a way
yeah i think it started as satire became
real i would imagine that maybe the
biden team is embracing it because
there's this rumor out there that the
left can't meme right and so maybe they
want to show that the left indeed can
meme and this is a way to like sort of
recapture one of the attacks against you
the
let's go brandon thing definitely being
a euphemism for f joe biden but if
they're able to turn that around and
talk about dark brandon maybe that's a
benefit to them and i also wonder if
that tied in at all to the optics uh
with the the speech last week that biden
gave in philadelphia
red lights and the military in the
background it was pretty dark yeah
yeah was that intentional was that to
play up the dark brandon thing i don't
know but during the speech which i
covered live it was so obvious that the
right was going to go crazy over the
imagery and they i mean predictably they
said it looked satanic which was
literally what i said during the stream
yep i mean we can give you some credit
for for calling that uh although it is
rather predictable it was very
predictable
i don't think it was a particularly
notable prediction it was so obviously
written on the wall yeah so anyway dark
brandon let us know if you like it if
you don't if you find it serious or not
and we'll be back tomorrow with a new
show and a new bonus show